okay so last Monday I told you that
early voting has started you can now go
and vote for better or work in Texas you
can go and vote for Stacey Abrams
against Brian Kemp in Georgia and
there's lots of other places early
voting is happening here in
Massachusetts as well
you might remember if I call your
attention to Election Day 2012 that I
had stories of voting machines flipping
votes from Barack Obama to Mitt Romney
and we now have reports out of Texas and
Georgia that say that it is happening
again
multiple Democratic voters reporting
that in Texas they tried voting for the
Democrat better o'rourke but the
machines selected Ted Cruz or left their
vote for US Senate blank there is one
complaint which says that the opposite
happened that they were trying to vote
for Ted Cruz and it was somehow flipped
to better or work the overwhelming
majority of the complaints relate to
people trying to do a party-line vote
where you basically press a button and
select all Democrats are all Republicans
which by the way I am against but it's
not really the topic of this story
supposedly this is a technical glitch
that happens when you turn a selection
dial at the same time that you hit the
enter button but the weird thing if we
are to believe that explanation is that
the voting machines that are being used
in the counties that are having these
issues reported are actually used in 82
counties and what that doesn't really
explain is why are the problems only in
six counties if it is a known issue with
turning the dial and pressing enter at
the same time wouldn't some people by
chance in all 82 counties be doing that
so that doesn't really make sense that's
Texas then we've got Georgia and Georgia
we've been talking about a lot because
Georgia is where Secretary of State
Brian Kemp a Republican is running for
governor at the same time he has been
purging voters he has been reducing
early voting hours he has been
eliminating polling places altogether of
course in disproportionately black
and/or poor and or democratic areas and
there
is now a report which says that votes
for Democratic candidate Stacey Abrams
have been switched to Republican Brian
Kemp Brian Kemp says it's not happening
is voter error it's people who don't
know what they're doing and it is also
simultaneously being chalked up to old
voting machines and this is just
something that's stunning some of the
old voting machines in use in Georgia
aren't supported by the manufacturers
anymore meaning that when there's an
issue the manufacturer says that's not a
machine that's like our current suite of
machines so we don't provide support for
it anymore
there should be a law banning the use of
unsupported machines full stop now I
know I know you'll say the companies
making them will stop supporting them
just to make everybody buy new voting
machines well that's really simple to
solve when you do a contract with a
municipality with a voting location to
buy their voting machines you get the
voting machine manufacturer to agree
that they will support that machine for
at least X number of years this is
voting this is one of the most important
things we do and the idea that we should
just accept well listen those voting
machines aren't supported anymore and
it's really nothing that we can do that
is disgusting and it's a joke and every
single contract should say you must
agree to support the voting machines for
as long as they determine they want to
do it now we also have an issue here
related to the Voting Rights Act which
is that both Texas and Georgia the two
states were talking about here uh used
to be jurisdictions covered by section 5
of the Voting Rights Act of 1965 which
meant that anytime they were going to
make changes to how voting was being
done they were required to obtain
preclearance from the federal government
in order to ensure that what they were
doing wasn't going to disproportionately
discriminate against minorities why were
they required to do that because of
their history of setting up voting in a
way that discriminated against
minorities now in 2013 the Supreme Court
made a decision they made a ruling which
determined that those jurisdictions no
longer need to pursue that free
clearance unless they've been given a
specific court order for specific
changes and now we find ourselves five
years after that decision in 2018 after
the 2013 Voting Rights Act Supreme Court
ruling and at least two of the
jurisdictions that previously required
preclearance to make the types of
changes that they've been making now
have voting systems that in practice
appear to be benefiting Republicans and
are being targeted to disadvantaged
rural non-white democratic-leaning
and disproportionately poor voters
anybody shocked
anybody shocked that that's what's going
on and unfortunately even my reporting
of this might discourage voters who
might hear me say votes are being
flipped and then they say my vote now is
I already was wondering if my vote would
even matter now I know it won't matter
because the machine will just flip it so
what you need to do is number one slow
down when voting number two look very
carefully at each selection that you are
making verify that the Machine
registered the vote the way you intended
to make it and then report all
irregularities film it depending on
legality I know that not all states
allow you to film you submitting your
ballot if you feel strongly enough that
something is going on that you want to
risk illegally filming your own ballot
that is up to you I don't recommend
illegal activity but I'm just saying
voting is pretty damn important because
those videos of machines malfunctioning
in this way get attention and they get
very quick attention and you send them
to me okay if that happens and you get
it on video and you send it to me I will
report on it make sure you are following
the show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me on instagram at David
Pakman as well one of today's sponsors
is Skillshare which is an amazing online
learning community that offers thousands
of high quality classes on almost any
topic first 500 people who click the
link under this video we'll get to
entire months of totally free access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up